to ensure your customers today remain
your customers tomorrow you need to
build with the speed of a startup and at
the scale of an enterprise with IBM
cloud you can take advantage of cloud
native development our secure public
cloud platform can considerably
shortened the journey from idea to first
release it has cloud native tools based
on open standards to transform DevOps
and also provides advanced cloud
services such as AI IOT and blockchain
to spark business innovation and we have
experience helping businesses reinvent
their development processes and how
teams work together in this age of
unforgiving demand IBM cloud can help
you innovate execute and deliver time
and time again keeping your customers
loyal and your business one step ahead
of the pack
you